dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir this is an
incredible paper from open AI in which
the goal is to teach an AI to read a
piece of text and perform common natural
language processing operations on it
for instance answering questions
completing text reading comprehension
summarization and more and not only that
but additionally the AI has to be able
to perform these tasks with as little
supervision as possible this means that
we seek to unleash the algorithm that
they call GPT to to read the internet
and learn the intricacies of our
language by itself to perform this of
course we need a lot of training data
and here the AI reads 40 gigabytes of
Internet text which is 40 gigs of non
binary plaintext data which is a
stupendously large amount of text it is
always hard to put these big numbers in
context so as an example to Train
similar text completion algorithms AI
people typically reach out to a text
file containing every significant work
of Shakespeare himself and this file is
approximately 5 megabytes so the 40
gigabytes basically means an amount of
text that is 8,000 times the size of
Shakespeare's works that's a lot of text
and now let's have a look at how it
fares with the text completion part this
part was written by a human quoting in a
shocking finding scientists discovered a
herd of unicorns living in a remote
previously unexplored valley in the end
these mountains even more surprising to
the researchers was the fact that the
unicorns spoke perfect English and the a
I continued the text the following way
quoting a short snippet of it the
scientist named the population after
their distinctive horn of its unicorn
these four horned silver white unicorns
were previously unknown to science whoa
now note that this is clearly not
perfect if there is even such a thing as
a pair
continuation and it took ten tries which
means that the algorithm was run ten
times and the best result was cherry
picked and recorded here and despite all
of these this is a truly incredible
result especially given that the
algorithm learns on its own after giving
it a piece of text it can also answer
questions in a quiet competent manner
worry not later in this video I will
show you more of these examples and
likely talk over them so if you are
curious feel free to pause the video
while you read the prompts in their
completions the validation part of the
paper reveals that this method is able
to achieve state-of-the-art results on
several language modeling tasks and you
can see here that we still shouldn't
expect it to match a human in terms of
reading comprehension which is the
question-answering test more on that in
a moment so there are plenty of natural
language processing algorithms out there
that can perform some of these tasks in
fact some articles already stated that
there is not much new here it's just the
same problem but stated in a more
general manner and with more compute AHA
it is not the first time that this
happens remember our video by the name
the bitter lesson I've put a link to it
in the video description but in case you
missed it let me quote her Richard
Sutton address this situation the bitter
lesson is based on the historical
observations that won AI researchers
have often tried to build knowledge into
their agents - this always helps in the
short term and is personally satisfying
to the researcher but three in the long
run it plateaus and even inhibits
further progress and for breakthrough
progress eventually arise by an opposing
approach based on scaling computation by
search in learning the eventual success
is tinged with bitterness and often
incompletely digested because its
success over a favored human centric
approach so what is the big lesson here
why is GPT 2 so interesting well big
lesson number one is this is one of the
clearer cases of what the quote was
talking about
where we can do a whole lot given a lot
of data and compute power and we don't
need to insert too much additional
knowledge into our algorithms and lesson
number two as a result this algorithm
becomes quite general so it can perform
more tasks than most other techniques
this is an amazing value proposition I
will also add that not every learning
technique scales well when we add more
compute in fact you can see here
yourself that even GPT two plateaus on
the summarization task making sure that
these learning algorithms scale well is
a great contribution in and of itself
and should not be taken for granted
there has been a fair bit of discussion
on whether open a I should publish the
entirety of this model they opted to
release a smaller part of the source
code and noted that they are aware that
the full model could be used for
nefarious purposes why did they do this
what is the matter with everyone having
an AI with a subhuman level reading
comprehension well so far we have only
talked about quality but another key
part is quantity and boy are these
learning methods superhuman in terms of
quantity just imagine that they can
write articles with a chosen topic and
sentiment all day long and much quicker
than human beings also note that the
blueprint of the algorithm is described
in the paper and a top-tier research
group is expected to be able to
reproduce it so does one release the
full source code and models or not this
is a quite difficult question we need to
keep publishing both papers and source
code to advance science but we also have
to find new ways to do it in an ethical
manner this needs more discussion and
would definitely be worthy of a
conference style meeting or more there
is so much to talk about and so far we
have really only scratched the surface
so make sure to have a look in the video
description
I left a link to the paper and some more
super interesting reading materials for
you make sure to check them out also
just a quick comment on why this video
came so late off
the paper has appeared since there were
a lot of feelings and intense discussion
on whether the algorithm should be
published or not I was looking to wait
until the dust settles and there is
enough information out there to create a
sufficiently informed video for you this
of course means that we are late to the
party and missed out on a whole lot of
views and revenue but that's ok
in fact that's what we'll keep doing
going forward to make sure you get the
highest quality information that I can
provide if you have enjoyed this episode
and would like to help us please
consider supporting us on patreon
remember our motto a dollar a month is
almost nothing but it keeps the papers
coming and there are hundreds of papers
on my reading list as always we are
available through patreon.com slash two
minute papers and the link is also
available in the video description
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time